-You got to go golfing with
your buds back in Atlanta.
-Hey.
-You guys are still there.
You got to take them golfing
with Jon Hamm.
-Yeah.
-That's pretty cool.
Are they impressed with
what you do?
Are your friends
proud of your success?
-I think initially
they were like --
they thought it was pretty cool.
But now, I don't know
if your audience knows this,
but Atlanta is like
the Hollywood of the East.
-Yeah. All the Marvel movies.
-All the Marvel movies
shoot there.
There's so much movie production
there,
that they are super blasé about
movie stars now.
And I was like --
My buddy Rob was like, "Hey,
let's play golf next weekend."
I was like,
"Great, I can bring Jon Hamm."
He's like, "Uh, okay."
[ Laughter ]
And this was a good game though.
This was a fun outing.
-What happened out here?
-Well, actually, so, this is Rob
in the hat there.
And he was down range.
I hit a -- I should start by
saying I'm not a good golfer.
-Right. This story seems like
it's going that way.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He was down range, and I just
lined up this 4-iron shot
and shanked the hell out of it,
veered off,
tagged Rob right in the calf.
-Oh, wow.
-Glorious bruise.
-Yeah.
-I actually think you sent us
the bruise.
I hope people can see it.
Yeah, you got him.
[ Audience oohs ]
So maybe it's less about there
are movie stars in Atlanta.
Maybe they're just not that
psyched you're back
'cause you hurt them.
-'Cause I hurt them?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's true.
But I don't know what
to tell you.
-Yeah.
-Look, it's hard to even
hear you over the buzz.
-I know, right?
This is so much fun.
-Hey, thanks for being here.
-I'm sorry.
I do want to say sorry to Rob.
-Oh, yeah. Of course.
-Yeah.
We apologize for laughing at
your expense.
Ed Helms, everybody.